こんにちははじめ社長です
アウェーですごいね今日東京のちょっと頭に来てるんですけどもみなさんアルファゲル
ってご存知でしょうかってがゲルって知ってますか
あげるって聞くとこ柔らかいイメージがあると思う
r
揺れてこう柔らかいもののことなんですけどもあれさあゲルというものがございまして
してる人もいますけどなんかシャーペンとかであるさあ切るのシャーペンであるんです
よめっちゃ柔らかいやつ実績がすぐにされなければかありましたアルファーゲルトは
愛華さんが開発した衝撃吸収
振動吸収素材のことでございますがこれすごいことにですね美麗の6回
18メートルから生卵を落としてもたった2センチたったに先生のあるファーゲルを
引いておくと卵はれずに受け止めるという山てないですか
ヴェレーナ600から卵を落としても割れないとアルファゲル2010あったでも
そんな飛んだまで衝撃吸収のゲルを今回防具として
ずう3していただきましたここでございます
これこれがこれめっっちゃで噛んだけど書いてありますこれある紛れで伝わるかわかん
ないけどめっちゃプニプニしてですよはもうばかり貼ってねすっげーブニブニしてん
ですよ
強いでこんなですね地蔵最強の衝撃吸収素材アルファーゲイルを使って
体協の男と戦っていび今日は最強の男と戦ってみたいと思いますで強度が
た
代表の衝撃吸収素材アルファーゲームをつけて始めたとういずなぜかは天使んど連れが
強いのが戦ってみたいと思いますや
天真くん強いひとつが最強なんで最強の男の攻撃セラーもたぶんこれがアルファーゲル
の防具を身に着けていればとかいい勝負できるんじゃないかと思って今日は戦ってみ
たいと思いますし長いことだけ
祈っ
ている
[音楽]
ブログで夏京田寝具ねー
アース
[音楽]
願いします外で吸っただけでちょっと電子インクのか誰がために
はいあるファイルを準備したんでこれでさあ攻撃を吸収して今日は倒しする防御力は
どうですけど声広がります
スタミナ切れを狙います衝撃形成するから打っても打ってもダメ違いなくてああ
頑張ってたところをです
この撮影でいますそれだけメイクとショップデー
いい
はぁ
[音楽]
haihai 0
あれはいえボード
いきましたーーー
ええええええ
どう動いたか
それはそうとこれ強いや1個3キロだから
図解1いいね地域を出るから気が合うと2期の50が高いということです
大
うーん1持ってもらう0倦怠感ですもう思いっきりでツーリングしてきて
goo
danejones
[音楽]
ています
ええええええ
持っていた
ん
じゃああーるもうじゃあ
わー
[音楽]
ええええええ
鳳凰
欲しいっ
ボディは
じゃないボディは痛いしたらー
ちょっともう一回をます
ちょっと痛いの
でもなんか最初大阪は大丈夫ん
なんだった彼らもう大丈夫だよ
すごい次ボディーさんないといいと思います合成師
命令性がある
結構分厚いんですっ
聞くのかなぁって言うんで軽いきりでは耐えられちゃったねー
ちょっと通目にもうちょっと行こうかなっていうふうに思います
持った
jr
あって
rar
ああああああ
ええええええ
voodoo
いっていい
me
んだーっ
0ねえええええプルオーバー鉄骨
焼きわー3発耐え者の声
[音楽]
い
kore はいというわけで
韻文と最強の衝撃して素材で戦っていたんですよ
3凸が入れましたでもどうもう一つあるよ
本気だった結構2台すごいよなかった花王
だろうあの最強もうこの天井区の本気の3番されるという非常に93
魔女でははいらっしゃいます
me
んはぁ
レベルはどれどれ
hey
[音楽]
eleanor